[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chérit les chéris est-ce que des
quelques aveux parier je paye 10 comme
la dernière fois vous misé un euro je
vous donne 10 euros c'est à dire pour
apparier soit en les laissant sans nom
je récupère 1000 wii parfait apprenti
vous permet au gardé son camp elle te
fais moi je me serais jamais mon coeur
ils sont ou non mais c'est plat ce cas
vous pariez sur thomas sotto j'avais mal
et je parie 10 euros sur thomas sotto
donc si vous perdez vous avez 10 euros
si vous gagnez vous gagnez sont
absolument on a 10 euro suggère un lieu
magique gagne quoi dans tout ça m'est
arrivé tu récupères t'inquiète pas
attaqué je ne m'inquiète pas tomates un
gamin sur 5 euros sur thomas sotto très
bien à crever 20 sur toi vas sur moi ah
mais moi je avec moi c'est turckheim que
deux barreaux non mais non son papa est
ce vendredi même si les chérir et chérie
attention donc on a on a tous acabits
voulait parler quelque chose oui sur qui
tu es - bb oui vous va oui d'accord très
bien alors y'a que matthieu delormeau
qu'un pays ait les mêmes hashtag
#civsocial hui comprendra au téléphone
tout à l'heure gagnera peut-être toute
la somme que je vais gagner c'est parti
on y va cinq mois commence le match 2
points d'écart ou pas bien sûr alors on
est professionnel
à la louche mais thomas sans pression
les lots de labarde t'insulte académique
mais tu joues pas mal c'est pas loin de
parler par contre tu es beau balles
d'échauffement thakral à abraham fallait
deux prélats lycéens vers hambourg sinon
c'est moi qui ait servi et j'ai pu le
faire une fois chacun
[Applaudissements]
alors si comme rogers je suis pas moi
paris moi je reste ici à londres quand
tu veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tout
il adore parce que c'était complètement
improvisé cette affaire on va voir
combien il ya quelqu'un tout de suite
sur twitter qui va remporter la somme
globale
voilà que vous avez donnée donc voilà
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des vins des 10
des 40 euros
[Musique]